I have the modern women want to have  some of that then they should do what I  do and mix with because I I find that a  lot of people who have negative  ideas about marriage is because they  have no positive role models of marriage  and if they even if they nowadays I've  realized that modern people even if  their parents are together and they  parents said like they're still married  they're looking at their parents  relationship or something negative when  it should be something you know they  might think oh my dad tells my mum what  to do or my mum was just a housewife and  they've seen it as something negative  where it's something positive so me  personally when I now even though I'm  I'm content with my man I still surround  myself with happily married feminine  women and their husbands and their  families because I sort of I'm like a  sponge I just want to jump in the middle  and soak it all up yeah I